[Music]
on this wednesday night under attack
reports russian troops have stormed that
steel plant in mariupol ukraine any
place in ukraine can become a target as
the un's chief human rights monitor
tells global news how suspected war
crimes are being investigated
heated exchange the prime minister
accused of swearing in the house of
commons
neighbors helping neighbors i gotta get
out and help help the people the fight
to protect a manitoba first nation from
floodwaters post-coveted post-traumatic
stress i was kind of having some
flashbacks the heavy toll on those with
loved ones in the hospital
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
for 70 days now russian forces have
relentlessly attacked ukraine and
tonight there are developments on a
number of fronts that steel plant in
mariupol the last ukrainian holdout in a
city russia has pulverized is believed
to have been stormed by russian troops
though accurate information is difficult
to get because russia controls access to
the site the mayor says heavy fighting
is going on at the plant where civilians
are still huddled in tunnels the u.n
estimates at least 3 000 ukrainian
civilians have been killed since russia
invaded and there's a new analysis today
of what's believed to be the single
deadliest known attack it was the
bombing of the theater in mariopol on
march 16th the one that showed the word
children written on the pavement outside
a detailed analysis by the associated
press including interviews with
survivors has found evidence the attack
was far deadlier than initially feared
our coverage tonight begins with redmond
shannon and a warning some of the images
in his story are upsetting
this video from a pro-separatist news
outlet in the donbass region shows a
series of heavy explosions at the azov
style steel plant it's not known exactly
when it was filmed but it was published
as a ukrainian government official said
russian forces are now on site at the
complex but have not yet taken control
of it and while some civilians are being
evacuated those who remain in other
style
they suffer it's thought around 200
civilians are still sheltering
underneath the complex along with
hundreds of ukrainian troops the last
holdouts in a devastated city among
mariupol's runes the theater turned bomb
shelter struck by russian shelling in
march a new analysis by the associated
press says evidence indicates almost 600
people died in its bombing double
previous estimates witness accounts
include one woman who'd hidden in its
basement
we heard a terrible bang ran into
another room and then heard another bang
my husband went upstairs to see what had
happened and he started to get
hysterical he said corpses were
everywhere on the other side of ukraine
the aftermath of another airstrike in
the mostly peaceful la viv region it
will not be an exaggeration to say that
any any literally any spot in ukraine
any place in ukraine can become a target
russia again targeting parts of
ukraine's rail network
the regional governor says everything is
being done to preserve the railway
system calling it the pathway for life
and cargo some of that cargo is arms
supplied by the west
including u.s supplied howitzers cnn
reporting wednesday almost all of the 90
units promised by washington are already
in ukrainian hands so using
russia's defense minister is warning
nato that any weapons destined for
ukraine's use are legitimate targets as
russian troops look to advance in the
donbass with no tangible victories in
sight the kremlin dismissed speculation
it will mark monday's victory day
national holiday by formally declaring
war against ukraine but the letter zed a
widely used symbol of the invasion looks
set to feature prominently redmond
shannon global news london
the european commission has sharpened
its sanctions against russia including a
proposal to cut itself off from russian
oil the plan calls for the 27 nation
bloc to phase out imports of russian
crude within six months and refined
products by the end of 2022 hungary and
slovakia both heavily reliant on russian
energy have said no and could be granted
an extra year to adapt to the plan
russia is europe's biggest oil supplier
and cutting ties would be a big economic
blow to russia
investigators are working to uncover and
document evidence of possible war crimes
in ukraine it is painstaking work
especially in what is still an active
war zone the head of the u.n human
rights monitoring mission in ukraine
warns accountability could take years
our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing sat down with matilda bogner
to learn more including about the
obstacles her team is facing
in a career that has led her to serve as
the head of the un's human rights
monitoring mission in ukraine matilda
bogner has seen more horrors than she
can recall
but never anything like this compared to
the other conflicts i've worked on the
intensity
is much higher the numbers of victims
over a short period of time is is much
higher than i have personally seen
in in other conflicts
executions force disappearances
rapes there are few limits to the
violations of international law u.n
monitors are investigating in ukraine
bogner's team of 60 have started looking
into 300 unlawful deaths those are just
the ones that they're aware of from
liberated areas around the capital a
fraction of the overall deaths in
ukraine we can't go to places like
mariupol
we can't go to places where there is
severe hostilities it's just too
dangerous
so i would say that's one of the biggest
constraints when those locations become
accessible bogner says the work of her
team will only expand
already she says nearly every person she
and the team have met have a personal
story of death that requires
documentation
their work to record everyone is no
guarantee of justice
prosecuting war crimes is an onerous
legal undertaking that can take years i
think even just documenting and making
public what is happening is a form of
sort of accountability at least at the
more social social level bearing witness
to horrors of war is painful painstaking
work bogner and her team share a solemn
sense of duty knowing what they
catalogue here could help how one day
history is remembered and possibly
accounted for
krystal gamansen global news kiev
ukraine
in the u.s president joe biden went on
the attack against his political
opponents today casting them as
extremists with what he called an ultra
mega agenda it was a ramp up in rhetoric
after the supreme court leak of a draft
opinion showing a majority of justices
agree the roe versus wade decision which
legalized abortion should be overturned
thousands of americans have taken to the
streets after that draft opinion was
leaked it calls the landmark 1973 ruling
egregiously wrong from the start it is a
draft not a final ruling but biden and
others fear what it signals about the
erosion of other rights in america
jackson proskow reports
the ripples of a potential supreme court
decision are foreshadowed in places like
tennessee one of 13 states with a
so-called trigger ban that automatically
makes abortion illegal if roe versus
wade is overturned we're prayerfully
hopeful that the supreme court will
decide in what i consider to be a
pro-life way and our tennessee trigger
ban can go into effect women will
suffer
many of them will die if roe falls the
stark reality is that abortion will
likely be outlawed in at least half of
the states
efforts to pass a national law
protecting access seem doomed this is
about a lot more than abortion president
joe biden has warned it's part of a
broader move by republicans to target
social issues as the party's far right
backed by former president trump
solidifies its grip on power
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
in ohio tuesday more proof of where
republicans are headed this campaign i
really think was a referendum on what
kind of a republican party we want j.d
vance won the state's republican senate
primary after courting trump's
endorsement he's staunchly anti-abortion
and backs trump's lies about the 2020
election being stolen they know where
their voters are and the voters are with
trump especially in the lower turnout
elections which are the primaries and
even perhaps the midterms coming up
across the u.s moderate republicans have
been drowned out as they warn against
the party's course
we won't win back the white house
by nominating donald trump
or a cheap impersonation of him
that hasn't slowed the move to the
extremes with roe versus wade still
undecided oklahoma signed a bill tuesday
banning abortions after six weeks there
are no exceptions for rape or incest and
in a play to the religious right the law
allows any private citizen to take legal
action against abortion providers
jackson prosko global news washington
there has been lots of reaction here in
canada to that leaked u.s supreme court
opinion abortion in canada was
decriminalized in 1988 but it's still
difficult for some women in this country
to access it and it has remained a wedge
issue politically some socially
conservative politicians and their
supporters continue to get fired up
about it that was abigail beeman reports
many conservatives didn't want to
comment
today the freedom of a woman to choose
belongs to her
and her alone canada's liberals are
quick to support a woman's right to
choose but the trudeau government has
fallen short on campaign promises around
abortion including developing an
information portal and changing
regulations to create equal access
across the country with penalties to
provinces that don't comply in the form
of clawbacks to provincial health
transfer money there is more to do and
we will do it should roe be overturned
in the united states government
ministers say they support americans who
may come to canada to access abortion
services i've engaged cbsa my office is
currently working with them to make sure
that there are clear guidelines new
democrats want liberals to take quick
action and include free birth control
and the morning after pill in the
national pharmacare plan in the face of
a liberal government that's been in
power for seven years that has done
nothing to expand access this is a
concrete step forward access to abortion
many conservatives won't even discuss
the issue the liberals say you guys are
fighting on the abortion issue what do
you think morning let's see the flames
won last night in a hell of a game but
not all for myself it's something behind
us
and i know that there's some memphis
want to revive that subject but for us
it's a it's dead and so we hope that the
new leader will will put a nail on that
that subject women deserve to be
protected and their rights deserve to be
fought for
and
uh and we'll continue to do that that
hasn't changed overnight but it will
likely confront conservative leadership
hopefuls as the race to lead the party
forward heats up as for last year's
campaign promises around access to
abortion services no one is offering any
timelines the health minister will only
say soon acknowledging the situation
south of the border makes things more
pressing donna all right abigail in
ottawa thank you well there were some
heated exchanges during question period
in the house of commons today prime
minister justin trudeau was accused by
opposition conservatives of using the f
word which is considered unparliamentary
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is with me david question period
can often get testy we know sounds like
it went over the top today
yeah it was a heated question period don
it wasn't the craziest i've ever seen
but still emotions running very high now
on wednesdays the prime minister tends
to take all of the questions in the
45-minute session and in this one he was
goading the conservatives over their
stance on abortion and then towards the
end of qp he got a question about air
force operations during the freedom
convoy
and the pm was offended by the question
what the member opposite just engaged in
is dangerously close to misinformation
and disinformation
and you hear all that that's when things
really started to blow up the
conservatives say that somewhere at that
point all this hubbub trudeau used the f
word as an adjective aimed at the
conservative benches now none of that is
caught on tape because all of the
microphones are muted whenever the
speaker stands up but when i asked the
pm if he uh fuddled he repeated what his
dad once said when pierre trudeau was
accused of the same thing
what is the nature of your thoughts
gentlemen when you say you move your
lips in a particular way
and here's pierre
what is the nature of your thoughts
gentlemen when you say fuddle donald or
something like that
so there we go now the conservatives for
what it's worth are asking the speaker
to investigate and hoping the prime
minister will apologize donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thank
you lending a helping hand coming up how
people are banding together to save a
manitoba community
[Music]
people in some parts of manitoba are
still trying to hold back flood water
after weeks of heavy rainfall hardest
hit are more than fifteen hundred
residents of the pegus first nation
they've been ordered to leave their
homes but not everyone wants to go
preferring to stay back and protect what
they can global's marnie blunt is there
tracking the flood situation tonight
marnie donna the water has now receded
just slightly here on pegus first nation
but work to fighting the flood isn't
slowing down
much of the community resembles a lake
after weekend rainfall and ice jams on
the fisher river caused major flooding
surrounding and submerging hundreds of
homes
more than 1 500 people have had to leave
their community but about 400 remain
working to save what they can william
anderson is one of those residents who
stayed behind boating around from home
to home checking on pets sandbags and
lending a hand were needed he's seen
panguist deal with major flooding in the
past but not like this i got to get out
and help help the people i'm always
helping the people even if there is no
flood i'm always out going going helping
somebody else
owen spence is staying too fending off
flood waters with sandbags and pumps he
and his father take shifts watching the
family home with water on his doorstep
he's so far been able to keep it at bay
but knows others are not so lucky it's
pretty sad yeah
a lot of families gone
few other people just watching their
houses and
hoping and praying too
now there is more rain in the forecast
for here this weekend but residents here
tell me they're hopeful warm weather
will clear out ice jams on the local
river and allow water levels to drop
significantly before then donna that
would be a relief marnie blunt on the
penguins first nation in manitoba thanks
body and mind to have the scars kovat19
are leaving on mental health
the toll kovit 19 has taken on people
physically over the last two years has
been well documented but what's received
far less attention is the impact on
people who watch their loved ones suffer
a new study looked at families of
patients and the trauma they experienced
and in some cases are still struggling
with today jamie morocco reports
for 80 days half spent in a coma jared
linder fought to survive covet 19. a
year later he's still trying to heal i
had to reason how to walk and
eat everything his partner ashley young
has supported him through it all but
when he was in hospital pandemic
restrictions kept her from his side it
was the toughest thing i've ever had to
go through
just having someone that i love
not like not knowing
if he was gonna be back
or
if he was gonna make it through and that
stress can have severe outcomes a new
u.s based study has revealed almost 64
percent of relatives of covet patients
in icu experience significant symptoms
of post-traumatic stress disorder ptsd
in the months that follow pre-pandemic
for families of critical care patients
the number was between 15 and 30 percent
that distrust not being able to be at
the bedside and participate in the care
of your loved one and the way that we
know was helpful the interplay of those
things was really traumatic to people in
canada mental health supports can be
difficult to access with covert related
ptsd on the rise psychologists from two
toronto universities created an online
resource especially for couples going
through covid ptsd is a chronic and very
pernicious disorder so
once people have not recovered from
their ptsd it's unlikely to recover on
its own young says she battled
depression in the months after linder
was admitted i was kind of
having some flashbacks and it was really
making my
my life hard to get through since both
have sought professional help
determined to heal physically
and emotionally jamie morocco global
news toronto